[تصفيق]
على خطى مالي تسير بوركينا فاسو شيئا
فشيئا يتراجع النفوذ الفرنسي في منطقه
الساحل خروج فرنسي ودخول للنفود الروسي من
الابواب نفسها ولكن عمليه احلال وتبديل
النفود جاءت على مراحل وفقا لخبراء
نهايه مهمه فرنسا التي يبلغ قوامها نحو
400 جندي في بوركينا فاسو تاتي بعد 10
اشهر من طرد قواتها من مالي المجاوره
نهايه في مالي وبوركينا فاسو وبدايه في
النيجر المتخمه للبلدين
الوجود الروسي داخل الساحل وافريقيا لم
يتم بين ليله وضحاها يرى خبراء ان روسيا
قامت بحملات دعائيه للتاثير على السياسه
الافريقيه لصالح موسكو في المقابل تم حظر
الاذاعه الفرنسيه في بوركينا فاسو وفي
مالي هتاف المئه امام السفاره الفرنسيه
رافعين الاعلام الروسيه
القياده العسكريه الجديده في كل من
بوركينا فاسو ومالي تريد حليفا جديدا نمت
العلاقات بين والقاده السياسيين في منطقه
الساحل حتى اصبحت روسيا الشركه المحتمل في
الحرب ضد الارهاب وتحقيق ما اخفقت فيه
فرنسا
تعزيز الوجود الروسي في منطقه الساحل
الافريقي لا يخلو من الانتقادات الغربيه
في الواجهه يرى الغرب ان وجودها اسهم في
انهيار بطيء لقوات حفظ السلام التابعه
للامم المتحده والموجوده في مالي انسحاب
لقوات المانيه وبريطانيه ودينيماركيه
وسويديه انتقادات لم تحرك ساكنا امام رياح
التوجه الجديد بمنطقه الساحل فبعد عقود من
السيطره الفرنسيه وتراجع شعبيهتها
لاقدامها بين الشركائها في افريقيا
علي السمان العربيه
[موسيقى]